Kevin O'Leary said it best salary is a
drug that you that you get to forget
about your dreams talked about that
earlier also if you live in the west and
large urban city being a millionaire is
almost meaningless today when I was a
kid the notion of being a millionaire
was almost unreachable it was it was
like oh only only a a certain type of
person can reach that and that's a
limiting belief that I created for
myself and it took me decades longer to
reach that achievement because I had
that limiting belief and I've talked
about this before how do you change that
you raise your standards if you increase
your standards then you have new beliefs
that fill that Gap right you know as
your razor standard sort of thing
um back to this point over here
Financial Freedom
um a million dollars doesn't get you
where it once did especially in a large
Urban cities you're talking Toronto
Vancouver Miami L.A New York Chicago any
big large urban center
being worth a million dollars isn't that
much like 10 million is probably going
to give you Fu money is basically what
I'm saying at this point
um there's essentially six sources of
income which I've covered in a prior
cast which I'll recap very quickly one
c-suite job CEO CFO two licensed
professionals so doctors lawyers account
and stuff like that three High ticket
sales you're selling Yachts Jets
mansions that sort of stuff for fame uh
sorry Fame with an audience so that
would include actors musicians
influencers even these Tick Tock weirdos
that dance around like monkeys if they
have a large enough audience they're
going to make a lot of money only fans
believe it or not you know these some of
these gals are getting paid 50 60 100
000 a month showing pictures of stuff
that you can just Google you know if you
really want but that's that's a simp
economy that's what Sims do to the
economy uh five stem software Engineers
tech leads I've talked to people that
work for the fan companies you know the
Facebooks the Amazons of the world
um you're doing well you can make seven
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
and number six entrepreneurship which is
basically what I'm leading into this
cast and what I'm going to talk about
some will argue oh but rich I have X
number of doors and people pay me rent
and they make me Rich blah blah blah
look real estate's an investment like
anything else so you can invest money
which will pay dividends but even if you
work one through five on my prior list
over there and you still acquire
uh wealth you're still plugged into you
know the Matrix Service like you're
still one of the tools sort of thing you
still need to comply if you're a
licensed doctor for example or a lawyer
for example and you've got all the doors
blah blah blah I've got this rental
income coming in sort of thing you're
still exposed to some risk you know oh
the next pandemic comes along sorry sir
you're going to take these jobs
otherwise we're going to fire you
me
right oh sorry sir uh uh you know your
tenants won't be able to pay your rent
anymore do you know how many guys I know
that almost got cleaned out because they
were landlords and people just stopped
paying rent because they lost their jobs
and you can't throw them out especially
in the wintertime here in Canada anyway
you can't throw somebody out right so
you got squatters living in your
property and you're covering the
mortgage and they're not covering the
rent anymore so it's coming out of your
pocket now you're very strongly cash
flow negative right
these are the sorts of things that I
look at and some people be like oh well
you're looking too far into it no
this is why I did fine during the scam
yum and I had my inbox and my DMs and
everybody calling and going they're
threatening to do this to me if I don't
do that and if I don't do this and I
gotta proof you know to keep over the
family's head my wife will leave me and
it's like look this is why I procure and
I think through these things so the
strategies are available anyway let's
keep going and why I'm talking about
entrepreneurship and what these tools
are
uh almost every actor doctor lawyer CEO
that wore their face diapers took their
jobs bent and easy programs in their
email bio on Corporate calls for it
I never had to deal with that when I was
in corporate
but it's a reality of today
they got to eat their woke rainbows and
bend the knee to whatever is trending
that month they have a new month for
everything now
a monster this part of the alphabet that
part of the alphabet the plus part of
the alphabet they're they're celebrating
it continuously I don't see that on the
day-to-day basis but I've still but I
still have friends that work in
corporate gigs and it's reality of their
life sometimes I see it in the email
signatures people message me and be like
I'm part of the marketing team or
something to do with this and I'll look
at their email signature and it's got
like pronouns in there I'm just like
no
anyway
so it's a monkey see monkey do sort of
environment most societies don't want
freedom anymore they want free stuff
that applies to the government
specifically right people people vote
for big governments big incompetent
governments by the way because the
government say oh well we'll we'll
create more jobs or we'll give you tax
credits or we'll lift the burden of the
amount of taxes you have to pay on your
fuel or something like that people like
yes give me that I want to vote for more
of that crazy but they don't
realize there's a consequence to that
which includes more control and more
involvement in their life they the state
comes into your house and into your
pocketbook and into your life we already
know that they're already into family
law you know you can't you can't even
live with a woman now in a way that
looks like marriage without the state
saying okay now you're married even
though you didn't take any vows and
because you're parting ways we need to
uh slice and dice you know all the
assets and it's just the way things are
right
so anyway
um most Society doesn't want freedom we
talked about that they have their agenda
it's got to be yielded to monkey see
monkey do don't ask questions do as
you're told the question that I always
ask when somebody starts complaining to
me about these things which I hear often
is well how is that working out for you
and what are you doing differently about
it I did a survey on the community tab
of the entrepreneurs of Carter's Channel
about three or four weeks ago because
people ask me about different things and
I said
in the survey what would you like to see
more content on
um improving relationships improving uh
long-term relationships how to make more
money self-care I don't know I put four
or five up you know what came in at
sixty percent how to make more money and
I find it very interesting that people
are asking about how to make more money
but they don't necessarily do things to
make life-changing more money
keep going anyway
most people just keep going into the
into that specific Direction they see
the code in The Matrix they see what's
going on they want to fully unplug but
they haven't done anything about it
the government your boss Society women
they don't give a about your
struggles thoughts opinions Freedom or
sovereignty
I want you on their plan putting their
lives paying the taxes in debt debt is a
slavery mechanism I've I've talked about
this extensively on my total that
freedom Channel yes I have a lot of
YouTube channels
so when I set up in 2009 when I was
running my debt business I've talked
extensively how they enslaved people
with credit card debt it's not designed
to be indulged in and then escape from
very quickly there are mechanisms
engineered into debt to enslave you to
keep you in that vicious cycle so that
you're always paying interest and you're
always under their thumb
very few people understand this concept
even when I speak about it they'll read
it they'll nod their head and then
they'll just go on with their lives they
don't do anything differently follow
rules ending the need to whatever's
trending to control the masses one week
it's all I already talked about that
part
so let's talk about entrepreneurs and
how they generally play
most play not to lose so I have a
playlist the podcast playlist on the
entrepreneurs and cars channel it's
called plan to win and they're really
just conversations about chasing
Excellence some very interesting guests
if you haven't seen it yet go check it
out but there's there's
uh there's a corollary to that you know
if you will and it's called playing not
to lose and I've said this before you
know in life most of the time very
successful men that get things done play
to win a lot of the people that just
sort of get through life okay play not
to lose and while playing to win and
playing not to lose sound like very very
similar things they're very different
when you play to win you know you
basically put your cards down and you
bet on that win
when you play not to lose you're
preserving and make no mistake there's
there's times in life where you should
play to win more and there's times like
where you plan on to lose if you're in
the Autumn years of your life and you've
only got a few decades left I wouldn't
say go out there and play one I'd say
you know preserve your Capital make sure
you know you're you're very conservative
strategic about how you deploy money
what you invest in stuff like that
that's more of a play not to lose
strategy that's totally fine but but if
you're young if you're in your 20s or
30s you got a lot of Runway ahead of you
you got to play harder you got to play
to win right and this is what
entrepreneurs do this is one of the
tools that they understand is when
they're going to get into a business
that they just play to win with it man
there's there's no effing around right
anyway uh nine out of ten businesses
fail so I came across the stat well over
a decade ago
the vast majority ninety percent of
businesses will fail within three years
okay
and then of the ones that survived
so
let's say ten percent I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out